right so yeah so this is just get this
out the way joint work simply you know
well so i should say that so a feature
of this workshop has been a lot of
highly technical and difficult work
papers lasting up to 69 96 pages or or
more even sometimes so it's not like
this so this is this is this is a nice
straightforward stuff i think to present
and so you can kick off your shoes lie
back and just enjoy the show right so
and i realize it's also going to finish
a little bit early because by this stage
a lot of my definitions and examples and
stuff you have seen two or three times
already so this can go a bit faster than
i was thinking okay so this remind
ourselves h calorie is just a synonym
for homomorphisms 2h so the fixed thing
is on the right-hand side in this in
this world so an h colorings
homomorphism from so you fix h and then
you look at home and morphisms from g2h
so those are mappings for the vertex set
of g to the vertex set of h such edges
of g map to edges of age but the non
edges don't necessarily match the non
edges as we this it's not induced right
so we were interested in such a
classification workshop so we're
interested in classifying problems like
this one so this is not actually the
thing i'm going to be focusing on but
it's just the warm-up act so the name is
h coloring instances of graph and we're
interested in a number of age colorings
of g and we can think as exploit being
explained we can view the set of allowed
colors the the vertices of G as of H as
being a set of colors which are being
applied to the vertices of G Co so most
of these are the things you are I guess
three of these you've probably seen
already so this is two colorings you're
you're forced
to to color the graph G with red and
blue in such a way that there are no red
red edges and lube Luke's there's no
loops on those vertices independent sets
we've seen so leave that three colorings
move seam and witham Rollinson which is
a important model in statistical physics
is here because it's an example of
something or the other as I can relate
to a bit late
so so dire and green hills getting
name-check quite a bit notation right or
terminology I should see graph is
irreflexive if there are doesn't have
any loops at all and it's reflexive if
all the vertices have loops right and we
say that a graph is trivial if it's the
irreflexive complete graph or it's the
reflector it's the irreflexive complete
bipartite graph or it's the reflexive
complete graph and as you are well aware
by now thanks to Dar and green hill we
know that if h and this is about the
only point at which h will be allowed to
be disconnected it'll be connected for
most of the show but at this point if
every connected component of h is
trivial then easily the h coloring
problem is polynomial-time solvable
otherwise it's number P complete so I'm
looking at the exact counting at the
moment going to approximate counting we
only have partial so this is a complete
solution Bert over approximate counting
in the F prez sense we we don't have
complete information but we do know from
less this talk on Monday that are now
let's just have the blanket assumption
that H is connected to avoid the
problems that liz is already mentioned
we know that if it's a non-trivial H
then at least this H coloring problem is
it is as hard to approximate as it is to
approximate bipartite the number of
independent set sets in a bipartite
graph ok that's the no life below this
okay so often in the CSP world if you go
to the conservative case things become
more tractable okay so what what would
conservative H coloring look like well
here's a his impossible well here's a
natural way it could look so if the
board conservative doesn't mean anything
doesn't matter cuz we're going to get a
definition right so we're going to have
now the graph instance G will come
equipped with the bunker with sets of
colors on the vertices each vertex will
have a set of loud colors and you're not
allowed to color it with anything else
we've seen it all we've seen this
already so a list H coloring is is an H
coloring which satisfies the vertex
coloring constraints and then guess what
list H coloring is that is the problem
where you're given a graph y on the
color sets and you're asked to compute
the number of listing coloring to the
growth so important thing to notice is
that the H is part of the is is is not
part of the problem instance it's the
problem specification whereas these sets
these s sub these are on the vertices
these are part of the instance and ok
the side doesn't matter whether we allow
or disallow loops on thee because those
can be if you think provided for a
moment you can encode those within the
set
so will disallow them just be specific
okay so let's look at the exact
complexity of exactly counting this
stage coming because that's not very
interesting because the diam Greenhill
result continues to hold if you apply
list so that the trivial cases are so
trivial that they remain trivial when
you have lists on the vertices so that's
easy to check and of course you can only
make things harder by adding lists so
the hardest bit goes through as well
therefore so the dire Greenhill
dichotomy looks exactly the same in the
list world as then on this world so
therefore we're going to spend our time
looking at the complexity of
approximating this stage colors okay um
so I guess we've seen this before what
does it mean to approximate counting
problem needs you've got a fully
polynomial randomized approximation
scheme f prayers which is the randomized
algorithm which takes the instance and a
error tolerance and gives you back an
answer which is correct within that
tolerance interpreted as a relative
error but you've seen proper definitions
already this week how do we compare this
is also you've seen how do we compare
the complexity of approximating counting
problem see we compare them using
approximation preserving reductions and
it it goes with the F prayers in the
sense that if you've got some problem PI
and PI Prime and pi is reduced ap
reducible to PI Prime and PI Prime has
an F prayers then pi also will have an F
press ok so you can use this to compare
approximate the complexity approximation
um
okay so that as usual we denote the
complexity that sorry the problem of
counting satisfying assignments that
boolean formula by a hash SAT and every
counting problem in in in the class
number p which were familiar with by now
is is AP reduced water numbers out so
the hardest problems in number p are or
the hardest counting problems of the
form that we normally consider are those
which are equivalent to set which are AP
introduce all with Sam
but it's important to notice that
approximate counting is not that hard
because even if you aren't problem mike
sacks you can solve it in the f % x by x
section for example you using the
technique the bisection technique of
valiant of vazirani so what you do is
you take the solution space and you chop
it in some sense until you keep
bisecting it and tell you've got nothing
left or approximately bisecting it till
you've got nothing there and you can
detect that using a just a decision
Oracle so it's at the level of NP and
that means and that gives you the
approximation so the number of
iterations is basically the log of the
thing you're trying to count and then
you repeat the experiment and that gives
you an estimate in the F presence or the
number of solutions however
there are unfortunately so at the moment
the approximation world looks looks more
complicated it doesn't sort of look as
though we've got well as you know and
know already doesn't look as though
we've got dichotomies or even try
colonies or anything so it's you'd be a
complex sort of world and so with a view
to making sense of it or beginning to
make sense of it we focus on one of
these problems which is of intermediate
complexity which is bipartite
independent set and start looking at the
things which are introduced full with it
and we find that's quite a lot so
although it's not a simple dichotomy
there does seem to be quite a bit
structure there for us to exam
so yeah so this is just repeating so
here are some interesting things which
are equivalent to bipartite independent
set ferromagnetic easing model we know
we can solve it approximately if there's
no field but if it has or even if it has
a consistent field always acting in the
same direction but if it has an
inconsistent field which operate one way
in one place on one way or another place
then it seemed then it goes up to
bipartite independent set counting down
sets in a partial order partition
function the winner rodents which is why
it's sort of sneaked on the slide
earlier stable matchings so these are
all basic with them
so actually so there should be a name
check here I guess of diet yeah should
be night name-checking co-authors Dyer
greenhill Goldberg right for this
initiating this study here so that
should be on the sly so now for the
purposes that you know as you saw
already this is not a complete
classification of everything that we
know about but at least for the purpose
of this talk it will be right so for
this talk we don't have to go beyond
these this three-way categorization
those things which have a randomized
approximation scheme have an efficient
approximation algorithm those things
which are equivalent to bipartite
independent set and you can think of as
being an intermediate complexity as long
as you don't ask me what that means
they're just thinks which you know
they're they're introduced mall with
each other they're even complete for an
exotic complexity class but otherwise
they don't know and those things rich as
hard as they possibly could be which are
equivalent to such
okay so what's the advantage of working
within the conservative world ie with
lists it's the following if you so we're
interested in a certain age so if within
it there is an H prime which exists as
an induced sub graph then the complexity
of the H coloring is at least as great
as that of the list h prime coloring
because of course if we have an a so if
we have an H prime color coloring
problem we can translate it to an H
coloring problem just by restricting all
of the lists to all the vertices to use
the colors which are in h prime and not
the general colors bidden age so easily
using the list we can carve out induced
subgraphs of age and if whenever we've
whatever the complexity of one of those
sub gross is the complexity of the sub
graph H Prime the complexity of H will
be as the least as big so that back
gives you a hell of a lot of power and
various subsets of these people here
look to the decision version of this
coming so this is does a graph G
equipped with lists of colors of these
vertices have an H coloring in terms of
federal and so this this indicates that
there's a sequence of actually three
papers which basically one does the
reflexive case one does the irreflexive
case and one does the mixed case
okay so this gives the hint that what we
what we need to do to look at the the
counting thing is is to look at it's a
look at hereditary growth classes
because you see that if we look at say
the class of problems which is bcz those
things which are reducible tube is that
that class will be closed undertaking
induced subgraphs right and so this is
called a hereditary so a great class of
grass which is closed under induced sub
graph is called accredit tree and yep
it's immensely started so if you go to
graph classes org you'll see what an
astonishing amount of effort that's gone
into classifying the possible things
that you can have so you're you're
you're starting you know at quite a high
altitude in climbing the summit here
might of the effort was spent and
showing that there is an H Prime yeah
that's for free now absolutely this is
yeah yeah that's that's why we're
completely at sea well we're not
completely at sea but we have very
partial information about the non list
case a lot more yeah this is a big
trading wind
that still leaves you it's still leaves
you with something to do but not not
like 150 pages laws okay so two here are
two fascinating hereditary growth
classes we go to look at me gather the
nice thing is we can view them in two
ways and they kind of do always so one
is ideal for proving easiness and the
other is ideal for proving hardness but
i thought i was telling you it's not
going to be too taxing this so one way
of looking at these classes so they're
called bipartite permutation graph and
it is a bipartite graph and proper
interval graph and one way of looking at
it is in terms of the adjacency matrix
right so i'm going to say a staircase
form is so a 0 1 matrix which may or may
not be square is staircase form if if
you look at the minimum position which
is the 10 yeah so each the ones in each
row contiguous right so it goes zeros
100 ver if you look at all
if you look at the left-hand end of the
one sequence that March is that's
monotonically increasing so the
left-hand leftmost one marches to the
right as you go down the rows of the
matrix and the same is true of the right
hand right this one in the matrix okay
so actually I think this is their own
it's an example next slide so you don't
really have to too closely graph is a
bipartite permutation graph if you can
show you look at the by adjacency matrix
so this is the one which or the Rossum
labeled by the vertices on one side of
the bipartition columns are labeled by
vertices on the other side if you can
permute them the rows and the columns
which is now independent these
independent right because this is by
adjacency matrix independently as some
that it's in staircase form then we say
that the the graph is a bipartite now we
go to the regular adjacency matrix oh
this is square we say it's a proper
interval graph if we can simultaneously
because obviously now the vertices of
the the row and column labelings are the
same so you have to do the same
permutations of the road well so if the
rows and the columns can be
simultaneously / muted so that matrix
has staircase form so that's the
definition Lisa these are quite
well-known classes now the graph theory
is would not put the loops on but it's
quite natural for us and we need them
they're so
well of course it's it so let's just
check that it is a proper interval graph
or I given you are giving away the
numbering all right one two three four
and you can see that vertex one is
adjacent to one and two vertex 3 is
adjacent to everything apart from 15 is
adjacent everything where's invitation
two three four five right so you can see
in this sense that it's very natural to
have the loops in because the diagonals
there for free right basically Assange
is connected Grove
okay so here's the trichotomy if you
have a connected graph as as Leslie
explained if you if it's disconnected
then you're in trouble because you don't
know how to if you have a mix of hard
and easy things you don't know what's
going to win so here's the diag reen
he'll bit it's trivial if H is trivial
then it's still trivial with the lists
if you're a chai so speedy seemly not
reveal if your h is irreflexive
bipartite permutation graph so it's like
it's the first to entry class then it's
equivalent to x part I didn't Bennett
set and the same is true if it's a
proper interval graph okay it's still
busy equivalent and it's going to be
reflexive in that case and in every
other case that is as hard as it can be
so this is just what it's almost a
repeat of previous slide but you can see
this is a this is trivial so it's a it's
an e reflected bipartite so that's FP
this is neither reflexive nor
irreflexive so it must be hard it must
be the hardest class it must be SAT
equivalent this is irreflexive but it is
not a bipartite but it's not even
bipartite okay so that's a gain in class
three it's against act this thing here
is a it's reflexive and it is a proper
interval graph with the with the
numbering one two three okay so that's
this equivalent so that one is a
whatever it is it's equivalent to
approximately counting bipartite
independent sets the independent sets
and a bipartite roll and then this thing
at the end was just there to sort of it
is it there's an example of something
which is equivalent to this because it's
a reflexive property interval graph and
here is something which is according two
beers because it's a irreflexive
bipartite permutation graph and this
numbering one two three of the rose and
the one prime Q prime three prime of the
columns is the witness to the fact that
that's a
okay so you can look at their it's very
easy condition to apply a mirror I
shouldn't imagine they're not just
polynomial time algorithms for computing
for deciding these things but not much
more than linear okay so let's just see
how this goes roughly speaking so good
so let's look at the the hardest part
and first I will actually ninety percent
of the time i'll be looking at this so
we're looking at graphs which are there
not reflexive proper interval graphs and
they're not irreflexive bipartite
permutation graphs so one thing they
might be is grass which are neither
reflexive nor irreflexive okay they got
some roots in some long loops and they
connected so they must yeah so given so
it's already hard for base monic
constant saving so your list can be just
constant size for the heart I mean
ultimately finding the small that's true
then yeah you'll see that yes that
that's entirely true as will become oh
no no no no no it's not is it because
you don't always find the small constant
safe graph in each no because so for
example H might be might be a cycle I
wouldn't know even though the cycle now
they'll actually you know though even
that I was worried about cycles but even
that's okay yeah you're right I think
there are no cases that aren't
determined by constant yeah that sounds
right to me yeah
um
okay so yeah so if it's if it's not
reflexive or irreflexive it must contain
you I mean there must be an edge which
joins a loop to a non loop so they must
contain independent set okay so that's a
hard it counting independent sets even
approximately is a hard problem so now
we just have to deal with irreflexive
nada bipartite permutation graph and and
the other one reflexive and probably
int'l so now this is where you can just
wheel in this this massive amount of
work on hereditary glove growth classes
and there's an excluded sub graph
characterization so a graph is a
bipartite permutation graph if it
excludes these three specific graphs and
cycles of length other than four so if
something is not a bipartite permutation
graph and we know that it's got either
this thing this thing this thing has
induced subgraphs i should say or an
induced cycle whose length is not full
and you just have to go through these
things and check that they work by work
I mean that they are at least as hard
you know they're as hard as they can be
so let's do this 18 x three AK as I
giving you the terminology used in graph
classes org and the gadgets so one nice
thing is that you get very hands-on feel
for why these hard H's are hard okay
this because they basically they encode
the antiferromagnetic easing model and
the gadgets are trivial or near while
they're okay they look trivial it yet so
they're their path so this is supposed
to be I should have done some better
graphics but what it's supposed to be is
supposed to be a path of length 4 1 2 3
4 with 5 vertices and these sets here
are supposed to be the allowed colors at
that vertex where we're the colors are
given by these numbers right so they're
each color well a number is a color is a
vertex of age
and the thing to know about this gadget
is if you read off the first color in
each pair 1 for 3 for 2 1 for 3 for 2
it's a path in X 3 and if you look at
the second component 2 7 6 5 127 65 1
it's also a part and somehow they
managed to avoid each other you see if
you left that if you left that three off
that would be a bipartite permutation
graph as we saw earlier and somehow when
you try to construct those two paths
they would interact you much but the
fact you got that little three there
means that as they and you'll see an
animation now so you'll see you as that
two traces out that part and there's one
place the red one traces out that path
your little dance that whoosh it can it
can hide up in three momentarily so they
don't interact too much and then come
back down and they're of it so so the
gadget so it all falls down to just
checking for each gadget that you can do
this little dance that the interchange
is two of the colors and intuitively if
that means that so so you've got a
gadget which twists the colors two and
one so it should be a different magnetic
now so why is that actually it's because
that if you look at the interaction
between successive spins or colors you
can code those up as two-by-two matrices
so for example the first thing 12 verses
47 is coded up by this matrix because
one can be adjacent to four well if you
remember what was on the last site and
two can be adjacent 4 and 2 conjugate is
adjacent to seven but one is not
adjacent to serve ok so there'll be a
two by two matrix which expresses each
of these in these interactions and there
are three possible these are the
possibilities that can occur and the
thing that does not occur is 1111 and it
doesn't occur because you
you have this little dance that shunted
so it's it's it comes out of not the two
piles not interacting too much they
interact a bit okay because there's a
one up here they don't interact too much
and each of these matrices has
determined at one that means when you
multiply them together you get to
terminal one yeah he has 10-9 sure on
the other hand there's a twist we
twisted one or two someone we unto this
which is determined a 10-1 obviously
right
yeah yes I've tied yeah twisted the two
things I did miss label the
oh here's a higher okay so there is the
slide that untwist yeah sorry that was
still twisted on that place I've
untwisted them here and now you see it's
9-10 which is minus minus one okay so so
obviously a matrix with negative
determinant two by two is basically the
interaction of antiferromagnetic easing
model only except that except that it's
not symmetric unfortunately here so we
have to do something about them but we
don't have to do very much because if we
go back to here we see that this this
graph has an involution it has an autumn
autism of order to which flips one and
two so that means if we've got um if
you've got a gadget that will do this
we've got two equally got a gadget which
does the same thing with one or two
interchange and so we do that so we've
got now two piles and we put them in
parallel and that will create a
symmetrized gadget which looks like this
and it still got negative determined so
this is this is a pucker
antiferromagnetic easing model and the
partition function of the anti pyramid
for a magnetic easing model is as hard
as it can be because it it code a minute
in it has within it max Cup which is
hard
and you can you can handle her so each
of these other things you have to just
check that there's little dance between
the one or two that will interchange the
ashes an aside for the connoisseurs of
her entry graph properties of which
there are at most two in the audience
you are probably jumping up and down and
saying way my part I permutation graph
aren't those ones which exclude
asteroidal triples and isn't an
asteroidal triple exactly the graph that
would enable you to do that little dance
they're moving 122 and shunting the
other one and this is exactly true but
unfortunately you don't know whether
you're in asteroidal triple is symmetric
between one and two so just to quell any
you know profound questions I was about
to get on the subject of my part over to
so so it looks as though you could do
you could combine these all into
basically one case but at the moment I
don't see or we don't see how to do that
so yeah so reflexive proper interval
graphs do the same you just do the same
thing and I well you got your own yeah
okay good well I'm everything works in
pretty much the same way so that's
that's part three of the result which
which talks about the things which was
hard as they can be there's the second
bit which talks about the things which
caused add abyss this hardness it works
so what you do is you you take any old
age which which is not of the dire
Greenhill form and then you argue that
it must contain as an induced sub graph
usually well it'll either contain the
path of length 2 or the path of length 3
something like this awesome anyway so
and those turn out to be all at least as
hard as miss miss easiness part is is
interested well then you go to the
matrix characterization so this is not
this is the nice thing about this world
is that you've got different
characterizations of these graph classes
one which is what they look I dual Ram
one yet what is like there exists a
thing and the others like there is not
exist a thing so they're absolutely
ideal for doing the easiness and the the
harvest bit ugly and it's not this
party's not you so it's it's okay if you
go to this paper it may not be
absolutely clear there what's being done
is what I claim but anyway it sits there
and so this is saying that using the
that staircase pattern for the matrices
you can code up an H coloring list H
coloring instance as has an instance of
bipartite into pencil well you you you
coat it up actually as basically down
sits in the Polish Lord above at ease of
this equivalent problem
um okay so what about what about weights
so that's that's the end of the student
for the stage covering bit as such so we
what would be the weighted version so
you would because this is approximation
we're really approximation gets really
hard if there aren't many interesting
cases basically if we don't if we have
negative numbers and the possibility of
cancellation so what we're replacing
either the adjacency matrix of age or
the buyer's agency matrix is so be 0 1
will be matrix of non-negative real
numbers and the unary functions which
the lists will be replaced by functions
which for each color assign some weight
and then there's a natural replacement
for you you know bit in the 01 world we
have the staircase condition and in the
weighted world that would become the
following or it's the natural it's a
natural generalization to say that each
to buy to submit so there is a
permutation of the rows and the columns
such that every two by two sub matrix of
the adjacency or the by jason c matrix
has non-negative determine so I mean
it's consistent at least with the 01
case
and so in this this version this
weighted situation this is also there's
also a trichotomy just the same so it
might look from the moment that what
I've just been telling you about it's
just a special case of this it just
looks like you take the weighted thing
and you restrict 201 but this is not so
for example and why it is not so is that
on the one hand you're restricting the
classes of problems by you're making
your life easier by restricting the
class of problems from general waited 20
1 but at the same time so it makes it
life easier the same time you're going
from general unary waits with the
arbitrary real waits you're going from
that 2012 list and therefore you're
tanger and arm behind your back so
you're making life harder and so it's
not clear where the trade-off might come
and indeed the results for the list case
is not just the result of way to case
with the weight crossed out and here is
this example so look at this it's it's
if that was a 1110 it would be the
independent set model but it's good now
it's gotta wait it failed you out out in
the independence that gets a higher
weight and so what happens as the graph
normally as the graph becomes as the
instance becomes the higher and higher
degree the problem becomes harder but
here are the higher the degree well the
independent set tends to become sparsa
and indeed
recent work on Risa ah should be we
mentioned already advances in to spin
models using the decay of correlation
idea show that for this model in the
absence of weights or lists that there
is an FP tears so there's a
deterministic approximation algorithm
for this on an arbitrary graph and if
you throw in lists it's not a hindrance
but that's not supposed to be completely
clear but somehow without you can see
you can use this to simulate something
which fix that pins to spin one and then
if you pin something to spin too it's
like pinning its neighbors to spin one
so so basically you can throw the lists
in and it doesn't doesn't make life any
worse so you definitely so in this case
you definitely need the ability to have
fields or unary weights of the vertices
which are other than 0 1 if you do that
then it jumps to being sat equivalent
and basically that's because its
determinant here is less than
less than zero so so using so using
permissive field makes the problem hard
but if you have crisp fields such as CS
people would say then it's easy so you
so it is a slightly so it is it is a
different classification yep it's okay
so another benefit you get in this
unweighted case is that what the theorem
I mentioned continues to hold with
bounded degree and in fact mount agree
six and this is the right answer because
one instance is one things you're
covering is independent set and that
becomes hard that becomes easy at degree
5 okay
and yet actually the other thing is that
turns out that independent set is one of
the few basically pretty much the only
thing which is that requires degree six
and most things actually only required
degree three
okay and then just i should say this is
not this is not just here to get half
the audience in name-checked in one go
but there is a paper which gives a
serious very serious
extension oh I forgot me one in there
one two three okay yeah that's right is
it okay good Oh greatest number of water
than a taker of stacks yeah but it was
it was a it was yeah it it was a
contender yeah so it's it's it's a big
generalization in a sense that it's
covering there's the situation we're not
not where the interactions are not just
binary but there could be three or four
way interactions and there might be
several different kinds of interactions
so it's a fool we're in the full CSP
world and it doesn't give a dichotomy
trichotomy sorry but in the buy junk
TIFF case so that basically it's like so
all the interactions of binary but
they're not necessarily the same binary
interactions between every pair of
vertices then you do get a trichotomy
and it's either decidable but it doesn't
have the explicit form given here so i
think the benefit of this is that you
look at h and you see instantly which
part of the world you're in you don't
have to look at multi morphisms and
stuff and also you get a very hands-on
feel for why the whole instance is a
hard they're hard because there are
linear gadgets which which mimic the
anti-fairy matic easing model but
actually the result is tantalizingly of
the same form it says at some very hot
okay it's at some high level what it's
what this result says the general CSP
resort is saying is that the complexity
is determined by the so if you know
about csps you'll know that it's
important to look relations or functions
and the relational or functional clones
that you've got everything you can build
up from those relations or functions
and what's important here is what
functions can you build up that just
talked about two of the spins and our
binary so they are so what functions on
just to place functions binary functions
two arguments and involving two spins
one and two what ones can you create in
particular can you create something
antiferromagnetic so stated that way it
sounds as though this should be quite an
easy thing to prepare it turns out to be
my hard ok so I think this has a nice
explicit hands-on feel to it but nice it
yeah Christian's comment say like to
chegando example so the list the lists
seem to give you quite a lot of Memphis
of power yeah soon as well very cleanly
and normatively because of that you're
showing on despite going to the easy
case would there be any interest in
concern considering the planar variant
here see what happens in that case
people in the planar
I'm sure it can be done I offhand I
don't know what we don't have the new
comes true yes that would that would be
a big like that yeah that would be yeah
that would be the absolute killer right
that we don't really know you so the
only results you could get would be ones
which are conditional on assumptions
like there is no F prayers for bipartite
independent set on planar graphs so you
so you could only do it modulo
introducing further assumptions and I
mean I've natural
no I I think introducing biss or
bipartite it better set personally I
think is is an ok move but then you
don't want to do this too often I think
yeah yeah yo yes Leslie has threats with
right that would be the problem yep
Nicki so usually the meta problem is
decidedly polynomial time so to be more
precise when we take share for deciding
whether a relation is on your own before
a fine of 0 manually can be done in
polynomial time you mentioned other
conditions namely permutations from
certain matrix or matrix have
resize condition tell us more about the
complexity of okay it's a so from that
permutation tradition it's not clear
that it's even polynomial bad these
things are nearly marches property
expert there nearly linear on they
actually are there are linea and then
the other answer is you you could go to
the induced sub graph characterization
guy and get Oh No okay it's not obvious
so these fixed ones you could check for
but then you'd have to check for the
okay yeah the cycles it's not yeah I
think I'll stick with just one answer
come to the same